[Música]
la visita a este antiguo seminario ahora
una escuela privada trae recuerdos
dolorosos jean grenet jean françois y
josep sufrieron violencia sexual aquí
cuando tenían apenas 10 años
había un director de conciencia que nos
llevaba a su habitación para confesar
nos ofrece y después siempre había una
pequeña charla cristian y luego él
empezaba a acariciar nos y acabábamos en
la cama que estaba a nuestro la habría
que te acudía otra víctima jean-marie
recuerda cómo se sintió atrapado por sus
agresores incluido un sacerdote
citó las palabras de uno de los
depredadores
debiste haberme detenido no está bien
que es un pecado y de aquí encontramos
la idea tanto del consentimiento como de
la culpa en youtube debilite miles de
personas más han presentado a sus
historias
rompiendo décadas de silencio sus voces
son la columna vertebral de un informe
que será publicado este martes por una
comisión independiente que investiga el
abuso sexual dentro de la iglesia
católica de francia como miembro de la
comisión el arzobispo de rehn
escucho directamente el testimonio de
unas dos docenas de víctimas de tu lujo
es doloroso en primer lugar por el
sufrimiento de las víctimas es de ti
pero también es triste enfrentar a los
abusadores me siento avergonzado aun
antes de la publicación del informe el
jefe de la comisión reveló uno de sus
hallazgos clave alrededor de 3000
pedófilos han operado dentro de la
iglesia católica francesa desde 1950 el
documento fruto de dos años y medio de
investigación tiene 2.500 páginas
algunos lo han descrito como una bomba a
punto de explotar